اعلن محافظ مدينه سيفاستوفو سيفاستوفول
الروسيه ميخائيل
اشتعال النيران في خزانه وقود بمنطقه خليج
القزاق بالمدينه وذكرت وكاله تعاسه
الروسيه ان السبب في ذلك هجوم بطائره
مسيره اوكرانيه وذكرت سلطات المحافظه ان
مساحه الحريق تقدر بنحو 1000 متر مربع لكن
دون تسجيل اصابات من جهتها قالت المخابرات
الاوكرانيه انفجار مستودع النفط في
سيباسبول وعقاب طويل الامد ردا على
استهداف مدينه اومان الاوكرانيه
واضافت ان على سكان شبه جزيره القرم
الابتعاد عن المنشات العسكريه الروسيه
تامر الصمادي تامر تطورات الميدانيه وكيف
يتفاعل خبر هذا الحريق
نعم وسيله المخابرات الاوكرانيه قدمت
مجموعه من المعلومات على صفحتها الرسميه
في هذا السياق تحدثت عن استهداف كبير
وصفته بالكبير وخساره فادحه بالنسبه
للقوات الروسيه وقالت بان هذا المستودع
النفطي يضم اكثر من عشره مخازن يتواجد او
تحتوي على اكثر من اربعين الف طن من
الوقود وقالت بان هذه الوقود تستخدم
للاسطول البحري الروسي في البحر الاسود
وهو الاسطول الذي تضرب من خلال المقاطعات
الاوكرانيه لاسيما مقاطعات جنوب اوكرانيا
وقالت بان هذا الاستهداف هو عقاب طويل
الامد وصفته بالعقاب طويل الامد ردا على
استهداف اومان وسط اوكرانيا يوم امس والتي
شهدت خسائر كبيره على مستوى المدنيين
هنالك اكثر من 20 قتيلا وعشرات الجرحى حتى
هذه اللحظه ساتحدث لاحقا عن عمان لكن
استطيع القول ايضا بان الرئيس الاوكراني
اليوم وجه الرسائل في ذات الاتجاه فيما
يتعلق بشبه جزيره القرم وقال بان الهجوم
المضاد الاوكراني يضع شبه جزيره القرم على
سلم الاولويات وانه يهدف الى استعاده شبه
الجزيره لكنه ربط النتائج الاوكرانيه فيما
يتعلق بالهجوم المضاد بما ياتي وسياتي من
مساعدات عسكريه غربيه لاوكرانيا وقال بان
التوقيت حاسم وضروري ان يكون هنالك سرعه
في الاستجابه من قبل الدول الحليفه القصف
ظل متواصلا على عديد المقاطعات الجنوبيه
اليوم نتحدث عن ميكولايف هنا حيث نتواجد
كان هنالك قصف على المواقع الساحليه وفقا
لعمده ميكولايف الحديث عن كوستروب عن يعني
ايضا اوتشاكوف وكان هنالك قصف مكثف في
الحقيقه القريبه من هنا من من كولاي وفقا
للسلطات المحليه هنالك قتل وجرحى في صفوف
المدنيين وايضا الحديث عن اكثر من 100
هجوم وفقا للقوات او السلطات المحليه
الاوكرانيه تعرضت له عموم المقاطعه
الجنوبيه والحديث هنا بطبيعه الحال عن
خيرسون وايضا حاكم خيرسون الاوكراني قال
خلال الساعه الاخيره بانه سوف يتم العمل
على تجهيز طرق للاخلاء اخلاء من تبقى من
سكان في ظل القصف والقصف المتبادل بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه وتذكرين وسيله
جيدا قبل يومين فقط تحدثت المتحدثه باسم
قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه بان
القوات الاوكرانيه تقوم بما سمته تطهير
الساحل الشرقي من نهر دنيبر الذي تتواجد
فيه القوات الروسيه في خير س